lava in the heart of this town
thankfully the people who live here got
out before it descended
among the first to be evacuated on the
island was rosie she's collecting
supplies from a donation center
temporarily homeless the molten stream
spared her house but others weren't so
lucky
it's like a huge loneliness a sadness we
don't know where we are the truth is
it's really hard really really hard but
we've got the strength that we're all
supporting each other through the
uncertainty
she's trying to keep it together for her
family but it's also overwhelming
everyone here wants to know the same
thing
when will the eruptions stop
for a brief moment we thought they might
have the tremors almost disappeared the
activity has decreased the amplitude has
decreased and we are examining why there
have been a
group of
earthquakes in the southern part of the
island and we are trying to guess what
is going to happen
this is what happened this plume of
thick grey smoke a warning signal it's
not over
and now officials fear the lava is about
to crash into the sea if that happens it
will create toxic vapor full of
hydrochloric acid it's dangerous to
breathe in and it irritates the eyes and
the skin people in coastal regions are
being told don't leave the house the
lava slowed down in this town but not
before it swallowed up their church
their priest is too devastated to talk
about it padre domingo guerra is a
friend
emotionally it's affecting a lot of
people me i've been here a long time and
the older people are stronger but
they're afraid of losing even more than
they've lost since last friday
emotionally i've found the neighbours
mostly quiet but the younger people
they're scared too because it's a new
experience therefore it creates a lot of
questions for them
every morning for days they've tried to
clear the ash falling from the sky
how long they'll have to do this for
they don't know and how bad things will
get before it ends all they can do is
wait to find out becky cottrell sky news
the palmer
well that possible pause in the eruption
has certainly not materialized as you
can see from these live pictures the
volcano on la palma still spluttering
and spewing its lava onwards to the sea
the fear there about the toxic gases
which did kill one person in the last
eruption 50 years ago we'll keep an eye
on that of course
amazing pictures there from la palma